he's on the mercedes-benz van phone line
right now
uh i have enjoyed his work on television
this past week uh longtime coach in uh
south carolina also in kansas state
frank martin here on the rich eisen show
how you doing frank
which how the heck are you man i'm doing
great how are you doing
you kidding me the dolphins just signed
the left tackle they signed
they just got tyreek hill yep i i grew
up across the street from the orange
bowl we're getting ready to roll again
i'm really happy for them so you grew up
across the street from the orange bowl
is that right coral you're coach you're
coral gables guy is that what you're
saying
little havana little havana next
neighborhood over havana
and uh we grew up playing on the the
dirt fields that were
surrounding the orange bowl that's where
people used to park their cars back in
the day and and uh that was our
neighborhood that's uh that's grew up
sneaking into the game to go watch larry
zonka and bonakani and larry little and
oh yeah paul warfield and the rest of it
no doubt about it shula being the coach
of it i mean back in the old day um so
we were actually wondering what's the
real march madness the ncaa tournament
or nfl free agency right now it's kind
of crazy well up until a week ago is
that you know march madness now it's uh
that i'm sitting around staring at the
wall so i'm i'm i'm a little chat about
the golfing free agency so here we go
frank martin here on the rich eisen show
okay frank so what do you think this
story of the first week of the ncaa
tournament
was what do you take out
yeah i think it's awesome i think it's a
total reflection as to what's happened
over the last uh three four five years
everyone's making a big deal
about the transfer portal this year
because guys are immediately eligible
but we've been averaging 800 transfers a
year for five straight years
so um
it's it's the the balance the the
the the difference between a 13 seed and
a four seed or whatever it may be a two
and a fifteen
um
those days are over it's uh the the the
13 and the and the four five and the 12
and so forth
they're a lot closer than they used to
be when you combine
transfers into one and done uh you know
there are certain schools that recruit
one and done's and those kids keep
coming and leaving so they stay young
and and and then the the you know a lot
of kids that are back ups at the two
seed
don't want to be back ups and they
transfer to the 13 seed and makes the 13
seed a lot better so
it's uh i think it's a direct
correlation between what we've had over
the last five six years and
and uh the present moment which i think
is awesome it makes that tournament even
that much more fun to watch no question
but then when we get down to the sweet
16 i mean how much of a run do you think
somebody like st peters can truly have
when you see what the blue bloods are
are putting out there having made it
this far what do you think of that from
yeah yeah rich
the
uh you don't get to the round of you
don't you don't become a sweet 16 team
as a fluke
it's it's really hard to get into that
tournament and it's really hard to win
in that tournament uh once you get to
sweet 16 you got a real team you got
real guys you you might not have the
popular guys
but you got real guys and when you got
real guys you got a chance to beat
whoever's in front of you and you're a
real team you don't
you're not at this functional team and
make it to the sweet 16. that just
doesn't happen
um uh so everyone that's in the sweet 16
um has a real team i mean they're
they're a united team and they're a
battle-tested team and everyone that's
in the sweet 16 has really good players
now
uh
like i always say everything's match-ups
everything that
you know when i was on tv last week i
used the analogy between foreman ali and
ken norton
uh i you know a lead toyed with foreman
uh elise struggled with norton
foreman put norton to sleep the the the
styles were just
opposites and they just uh created
problems for each other and uh and it's
the same way in the tournament i think
the match-ups
uh is a lot more important than the name
on the jerseys right now does that make
saint peter's buster douglas frank does
that make saint peter's in your
announcement no because no because they
were never fat they didn't have to get
shaped they those guys those guys were
young and hungry from the word go
so what do you think matt painter of
produce thinking right now with shaheen
holloway talking about how he's got kids
from new york and new jersey and they
don't i'm sure you might have heard that
sound bite where he's like uh yeah
they're they're not afraid of anybody he
goes uh they're not pushed around we do
that is what he said yeah no yeah well
that's who shaheen was as a player
anyone that knows shaheen and remembers
him i've known shaheen since he was a
young kid i mean he played for kevin
boyle at st patrick's in new jersey in
high school
and i've known shaheen forever shaheen
shaheen
is fearless and when you see his team
play they've taken on his personality
they're fearless and he means what he
says i i think matt uh i mean matt
painter is not going to lose sleep
because shaheen holloway is talking
about he's got tough kids matt painter
has tough kids um
the whole thing is match-ups uh and you
know matt painter has two big old bodies
inside that i don't think st peters has
so that's a major problem uh for saint
peter's is how are they gonna identify
and deal with trayvon williams and and
the big kid
edna or so i can't pronounce his name i
apologize
um
you know but but then again matt
painter's team purdue
uh based on last week when i studied
their numbers a little bit
defensively they have not been a highly
efficient team they've been okay but not
great
and and keeping
those saint peter's guards out of the
lane
is going to be a big big challenge for
her for for purdue so um uh it's it's uh
it's all match-ups and and uh but that
matt matt i can tell you this rich
matt's not rolling in bed right now
worried about
shaheen having tough kids and
uh and and shaheen that's who he is and
i'm really proud for for who he has
continued to grow to become
and uh how good a coach he is right now
frank martin after a stellar week on tv
joining me here on the rich eisen show
talking ncaa tournament so um you've
been talking about match-ups and and
that's um what it's all about certainly
now
that uh we were in the sweet 16 which
kid in the tournament is the biggest
match-up problem which team has the
biggest match-up
problem for anybody do you think i i
think it's not even close i think it's
the young man matheran from arizona i i
think he he uh
i think he presents a major problem for
everybody uh because of his rebounding
ability his play-making ability his size
his shooting his athleticism
um i i think he's the the
the biggest
hurdle for for anyone to deal with right
now um
it's uh interchangeable players are are
in my belief and multi-skilled players
in my i don't care how high you can jump
you got no skills it's easier to match
up with you but when you're a
multi-talented player with size and
athleticism uh
and that's what that young man presents
i i think he's the hardest matchup for
everybody what do you think of timmy
what do you think of gonzaga's ability
to maybe have somebody like him with the
other
complimentary parts and uh dynamic kids
around him what do you think of
gonzaga's chances as a one seed right
now yeah i think it's i think timmy's a
big-time player i by the way i love him
because you know i'm battling alopecia
so he's got the best mustache so i'm
really really jealous
um i i love him i
he's an old-school blue-collar
no-nonsense winner you know he doesn't
wow you with dunking he doesn't wow you
with like all these incredible fade
aways in between the legs during the
game ends he's as efficient as anybody
on the court and 95 percent of the time
his team wins and he's got a lot to do
with it i think he's
i think he's uh he's everything i root
for in college basketball
frank martin what do you think
the coach k finale um how that's playing
out in that duke locker room i can you
know obviously it's it's
you know we in the media are
we're all in uh on following it and if
you know coach k cuts down the nets and
finishes his career i mean that might
set off 72 straight hours of
conversation even though it's masters
week and opening day of baseball that
week
but but the kids in that locker room um
don't you that what a bunch of a lot of
pressure that would be on these kids to
make it happen
right now don't you think yeah yeah no
absolutely i mean i was going to post a
video of belly flopping in my pool i was
hoping you guys speak about that instead
of coach k but you know do you guys want
to speak about coach k winning games i
i'm all for it so uh um
no it's it's a great story i mean i i i
think that last home game
uh just the whole attention because
duke's a really young team if you pay
attention
um they they they uh
i think that moment was just really
difficult
that's what i would think and i think
coach k was as much joy and as much
having a hundred former players or
whatever it was
as much joy as that brought
i don't want to speak for coach k but i
know there was there had to be some kind
of concern because you got to play the
game you're trying to win you're not
trying to just celebrate your life your
journey as a coach and
but i think they're playing better i
think getting away from that game
uh they played really well in the acc
tournament i thought up until the
championship game
um but virginia they kind of hit
lightning in a bottle uh virginia tech
did and and made that run and um and uh
but i think duke's playing really well
right now i i it would be it would be an
amazing story uh because
i tell people all the time my everyone
talks about our pressure defense and
what i coach and teach that's a it's a
combination what i learned from my high
school coach
and and as a senior in high school being
in the same tournament as tommy amaker
and and then following duke basketball
when tommy became a freshman to see
him pressure the ball and johnny dawkins
and billy king denied the wings and
and that duke pressure
combined with what i learned from my
high school coach who i was his
assistant coach for many years um
developed that mindset and you're
talking about a little hispanic kid from
miami florida where we had no pro
basketball no college basketball uh all
i had was uh seeing tommy amaker and
then trying to watch duke on tv
and he impacted
me
uh as a basketball person uh and that's
the the value that that uh mike
schuszewski's had to our game and our
profession and so many people for so
many years well frank uh we're scouring
your uh your twitter handle right now um
don't see any uh video of you belly
flopping into your pool where do we find
such a thing frank no i i was gonna post
it oh the same day coach duke placed the
championship i'm going to post a picture
of me
belly flopping i thought more people
would pay attention to that than coach k
winning
well let's give that a whirl frank let's
be honest
i mean if we already saw kelvin sampson
with his shirt off i mean uh we're you
know let's uh i i think that's just a
natural progression of things frank hey
rich i i i tell bruce pearl and
musselman and i will tell kelvin when i
speak with him you know i did that my
whole life growing up in miami now i'm
an old man i don't need to be showing
people my body
[Laughter]
you know it's like listen i worked
really hard yeah for about 24 years to
have a six-pack
i had to work a lot harder for the last
40 years to have a one pack so it's it's
uh
you know it's uh uh
keeping this one pack i've grown is a
heck of a lot harder than having a
six-pack well uh now i'm now i'm rooting
for coach k to make that uh that that
final because we're gonna hold you to it
frank that's what we do here on this
show we hold people to what they say
that's what we we're we're all about
accountability you know what i'm saying
you have my word that if duke's in the
championship game for whatever it's
worth okay between you and me yeah i
will post a video belly flopping in my
pool okay you got it uh it seems like
you're really good at this well it seems
you are uh really good at this tv thing
frank is this is this your your next go
around here or do you have coaching out
of your system or you don't what do you
think i still want i want to coach i
mean this was last year i was really
beat up last year rich
last year was a complicated year for
everyone in our world
uh
me personally it was it just beat me up
last year was really difficult between
my health
professionally it was difficult i wasn't
happy with my private dealings with
the people i worked for
it was it was just a complicated year
for me i'd never been in that moment
like i was last year when you go through
that you question what you do
uh but but i as i got removed from last
spring and the the players came in the
program and the way that my team fought
and
listened to me and the way we played
made me realize there's nothing wrong
with me and professionally and and and
my health is good again so i'm able to
if i don't have the energy to help young
people
then i don't need to coach and but i've
got energy again and i'm excited and so
i want to get back on the saddle but it
takes an athletic director to hire me
and
if someone's willing to give me a job
i'm willing to listen if not uh then you
know one day i might try that television
thing and um you know see how it goes
it's it's i think life is
has filled my life has been filled with
incredible people and stories
and when i get up there
i'm sharing the stories that i've lived
and i'm talking ball which is what i've
done my whole life 38 years on the
sideline so it's it's uh seems pretty
easy to me well um
will you do the next week
or it was just one week and and finished
are you back out there this week frank
did we see you
now i don't have anything in store that
was uh that was a commitment i was asked
about a month before the end of the
season okay uh and i am assuming we
didn't make the tournament i agreed to
do it and as soon as we weren't picked
on sunday they called and confirmed so
that's the only thing i had on the on
the docket so you got something i'll
come over and hang out with you well
frank uh
uh don't uh don't uh you know put this
number in your phone i'd love to
continue to chat with you throughout
this tournament and get your your two
cents on everything um i and you know i
i i'm a friend of rex chapman's as well
i saw you know he posted something you
said about youth sports and parenting on
on his twitter handle it went viral for
a reason because you have a message and
you've got a voice
coach well you know
you you if what i say makes sense and
you need me i'm a phone call away i'm uh
uh unlike the previous 38 years of my
life i've got some free time on my hands
okay well look for my call again so
between that and the belly flop we'll
chat again okay
okay thanks thanks coach appreciate the
two cents
thank you thank you you got it that's uh
frank martin everybody right here on the
rich
awesome wow fun guy
why wouldn't an athletic director take a
shot on frank martin here that's a great
question rich hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here